1934 2021 87 années de présence
militaire à châteaudun ne s'effacent pas
d'un trait de plume et pourtant pas de
défilé militaire
juste un rassemblement un mouvement de
troupes dans les règles de l'art sobre
et digne
même pour les plus aguerris la pilule
est amère
c'est toujours une grande émotion on
s'est peut-être pas la première fois
mais c'est toujours une grande émotion
parce qu'on pense à tous ceux qui ont
servi ici tous ceux qui ont travaillé
tous ceux qui ont vécu aussi avec leurs
familles dans la région qui était
attaché et forcément ça laisse pas
indifférent c'est en 2014 que le sort de
la base a été scellé en devenant un
élément r rattaché à la base aérienne
123 or libris
le compte à rebours avait commencé sa
fermeture définitive est désormais
consommée pour les médaillés du jour
c'est le ton des souvenirs et des
regrets c'est une journée particulière
parce qu'en fait effectivement le site
ferme et pour moi effectivement il ya
qui passe mon coeur comme effectivement
mais ça c'est le jeu j'irai dé
restructuration de l'armée de l'air
depuis depuis le début de sa création et
puis là on n'y peut rien entre son nez
j'exige un petit pincement au coeur mais
qui montre une l'on tond la base
aérienne de 179 a été le principal
bassin d'emploi de cette commune 1200
militaires sans compter les familles
désormais ce sont les 450 hectares du
site qu'il faut redynamiser
on a trois fermetures militaire à
châteaudun et amath kellerman
aujourd'hui la base aérienne
nous y sommes préparés on a un gros
préjudice pour châteaudun pour le grand
château bas et même au delà
mais on a un potentiel civile on a un
potentiel aéronautique qu'il faut
maintenant développer tous ensemble le
passage de deux avions rafale enfin des
cérémonies moteurs rugissants
or a été perçue comme un dernier salut
fraternel